um so kind of combining this
philosophical term that we seem to have
taken with
if you do how did you decide to look
abroad as one focus of your of your
philanthropy versus things closer to
home you know I get asked that a lot and
that's a good question because that
honestly I can tell you much more about
the education system in Ghana than I can
about New York City Public Schools which
is where I live and the reason really is
kind of by circumstance so one thing
that we I was actually volunteering in
Tanzania and I met my mother in Ghana
because we'd heard that opportunity
international was just kind of beginning
to lend to schools they weren't sure how
to do it or you know kind of what the
problem was we were just forming the
foundation and so we met up in Ghana and
started just kind of asking lots of
questions and saw this opportunity that
there was a gap here in this market that
microfinance institutions couldn't
figure out how to lend to schools and
schools couldn't figure out how to
manage themselves well enough to get
these loans so there was a there was an
opportunity there to create a program
and that's that's really why we ended up
there so it wasn't something where we
said here's this idea where should we go
we found it in the communities that we
ended up working in and now we're
looking at replicating that program in
other places